thanks charlie the greatest pleasure in
the book business is introducing writers
and there's no writer more fun to
introduce the Rick Bragg you can read
about Rick's literary successes in the
program that you've got about this
evenings event or even on the book sense
flyer that has him number five in the
nation for the book even came out and of
course you can read about all his
literary accomplishments on his dust
jackets but tonight we're going to share
a little information you won't find in
any reference material as everyone here
knows Rick Bragg is one of America's
greatest storytellers when the time
comes that he's written his final
chapter we think he'll go down as one of
the best that ever was many say he's
even more entertaining on the stage than
on the page and you'll find out in just
a minute one thing we will assure you
he's a better person than he has a
writer or an entertainer and here just a
few hard facts that we know about that
will back up that flame all over but the
shouting has sold over a million copies
but before you hit the old boy up for a
few bucks you know how much he put in
his pocket from the sale of those
million-plus books we know the precise
exact dollar amount its zip zero nada
not a dime Rick insisted that this book
was about his momma and she received all
the royalties
that's all right after the tremendous
success of schouten publishers were
literally knocking down Rick's door to
publish his second book and a few of us
asked Rick if he would consider giving
that book to the University of Alabama
press they didn't have much to offer
financially in fact they were the low
bidder on the list by far Rick's agent
wasn't very happy but folks around here
were because indeed Rick gave the rights
to his second book to the University of
Alabama press those of us who know Rick
Bragg know he is not a bottom line guy
he lives his life exactly the way he
writes his books from the heart when
chaton was really sizzling Rick was on
tour in England and became so ill the
doctors put him in the hospital he
informed them this just wouldn't do
because he made a commitment to speak in
Monroeville Alabama in the USA and had
to be released country to doctor's
orders
Rick checked himself out of the hospital
took a cab to Heathrow Airport and flew
all night from London to Atlanta
arriving in the wee hours of the morning
he jumped in his car drove to
Monroeville getting there just in time
to shower shave and change clothes for
the event we picked him up at the motel
rushed him to the courthouse where he
was speaking with only minutes to spare
but there we encountered an elderly lady
who was having difficulty negotiating
the narrow steep stairwell Rick was
zonked jet-lagged and poot
and hadn't had anything to eat except
the juice and roll he threw down in the
car but there was no stopping Rick from
half carrying that lady up the stairs
before we could introduce him finally
many of you have asked at these low
prices
how in the world can the crisis center
have any proceeds leftover the answer is
simple the star of the show is working
for free surely many of you have worked
on civic and charitable organizations
bringing in big-name attractions when
the big names personal payday ended up
killing the fundraiser not rick bragg
and this is his third event of the day
before we bring rick up
let me ask them when the show is over
you remain seated until we escort rick
outside to his sign-in table we intended
to have the books pre signed but Rick
wanted to meet everybody and sign the
books in front of you and say hello etc
so he said he'll sign your books that
you brought in and as many as you'd like
to buy for friends and as many as you
can carry and knowing Rick you'll
probably help you carry them if you get
a big load if you don't already know the
camera back here is from c-span and
we're being beamed to all 50 states you
think it's a shock for the rest of the
country to see all these folks in
Alabama on a Saturday night turn out to
listen to a writer
and pay 30 bucks for the privilege let's
um turn rillettes everybody turn I give
a big wave to Chicago and San Francisco
and New York Miami hi y'all
and and all the other 37 stops on Rick
Bragg's book tour and you folks out
there if you have the opportunity to
visit Rick Bragg in your town grab it
probably none of us here ever met
Ava's man although when you read the
book you'll feel that you know him
tonight as Ava's man's grandson is about
to enthrall us let's welcome back to
Birmingham Alabama's man Ric brave
thank you very much that is the most
I've heard one man lie since I was at
our last family reunion let me try to
set a few things straight for my own
credibility first off Jake it didn't
sell no million copies have you lost
your mind it sold somewhere between 15
and a million I wish you did sell me and
I'd buy my mom a gold monkey and put it
out in the middle of the yard and second
of all I checked out of a hotel room not
a hospital
and it was Gatwick and as for that
elderly woman that I carried up the
stairs first off she didn't weigh that
much and she was about 24 so Jake you
should not make me just start to lie
should not begin the thing by just
having to cover up yours so thank you
all very much for coming out tonight I'm
not at all surprised to see this many
people from from Alabama out to listen
to a rider talk I'm surprised you came
out to listen to me talk I guess there
was anything on TV but thank you
many of you have been real kind to me
about the book about my mom about all
over both shouting and I appreciate it
wrote that book for her so I guess it
was kind of selfish and the fact that
there's too many of you liked it tickle
me to death this one was the new one was
a lot more selfish even than that I
wrote the book about my grandma's
husband grabbed my Labor's husband my
grandfather because I wanted to build me
a grandfather and there's not much
better in the whole world than to be 39
40 years old and discover your
grandfather what a great thing to be
that old and then get to know him a
little bit we built in from the dirt up
so I hope you like it let me read you a
little bit it's okay
I knew when I wrote this book that I
couldn't explain charlie bund them to
you unless I explained my grandma Ava
this is who she was she was old all my
life even when I was sitting in the red
dirt fascinated with my own toes
Ava's face had a line in it for every
hot mouse you ever walk for every fit
she ever threw her hair was long and
black his crows streaked with white in
her eyes behind the ancient yellowed
glass of her round spectacles were pale
pale blue almost silver the blind had
eyes like that that color but Ava could
see fine Ava could see forever she could
tell your fortune by gazing into the
drug's of your coffee cup and swore that
if the bottoms of your feet itched you
would walk on strange ground
she could be gentle as a baby bird and
sweet his divinity candy but if her
prescription was off some of y'all sound
like you've been there but if her
prescription was off or she just got mad
she would sit bolt upright in bed at 3
o'clock in the morning and dog cuss
anyone who came to mind including the
dead someday she would doze in her
rocker and speak softly to people that I
could not find even by looking under the
porch now I know I was just listening to
her dreams and her time she buried two
daughters one just a baby and one
full-grown and when she passed 80 my
aunt's just stopped telling her when
people she loved had died out of
kindness I suppose near the end of her
life as her mind began to wobble she
would recall how pretty my ex-wife
looked at Christmas dinner 18 years ago
and not remember yesterday but when I
think of her now I think of a woman
still strong and hard in her late 60's a
woman with a banjo propped against the
foot of her bed 10,000 hairpins in the
pocket of her dress and more
personalities and
State Hospital in Tuscaloosa I think
about how the sudden summer
thunderstorms rattled the window glass
and make cups jump off their saucers and
how unimpressed the old woman would take
a dip of snuff and mumble Oh Devil's
beating his wife because she was old and
could be trusted with babies and
half-wits which pretty much qualified
her to look after me it was her job to
watch over all of us when my mother her
sixth child went to work she looked down
on me from her rocker talking to me and
actually grew older herself in time I
could even gauge that old woman's mood
by the pace of cherished squeaking
runners on the bare pine planks slow
when her mind was restful quick when she
was mad and fast racehorses fast when
she was remembering sheer power of it
would send those runners - squeaking
fierce and hot back and forth and to
this day I still wonder how the whole
damn thing didn't just blaze up from the
friction of it burn the house down
she'd been widowed young and never
remarried and as a child I just assumed
she had always been that way
an old woman alone there was a man once
a peddler for the sacks and candy
company it seemed to have a lot more on
his mind and saltwater taffy but if that
little old man was a suitor he was
pitiful at it and he did not give up so
much as just fade away that did not stop
her grandchildren from kidding her about
him from asking if she was going to run
off with him someday and his panel truck
full of pecan logs
grandma'll we would ask your gonna get
you a man most times she just sniffed
and ignored us sometimes she'd slap her
heavy black shoes down hard on the porch
applying the brakes and the rockers
runners would freeze in mid squeak we
fled usually because she's prone to
strike out quick as a rattler and knock
us upside the head but instead of
hollering or swinging at us she just
start to grin as if something that had
gone cold and her memory had begun to
glow for just a second or two in time it
was probably just her medicine again but
it is better to believe it was the speck
of heat from something that once
crackled and roared along the banks of
the Coosa River back when it was wild in
the days before the Power Company dams
turned it into a big brown faucet that
could be turned on and off it will no
Hahn's she would say ain't gonna get me
no man and then she would start to rock
again with satisfaction I had me one his
name was Charlie Bunner and he was
probably the only man on earth who could
love that woman and not perish in the
flame
he was a tall bone thin man who worked
with nails in his teeth and roof and
hatchet in a fist as hard as Augusta
Brick who ran a trotline across the CUSO
baited with chicken guts and caught
washed tubs full of catfish who cooked
good white whiskey in the pines drank
his own product and sang laughed and
Buck banks to under stars he was a man
whose tender heart was stitched together
with steel wire who stood beaten and
numb over a baby's grave in Georgia then
took a simple-minded man into his home
to protect him from scoundrels who like
to beat him for fun he was a man who
inspired backwards legend and the kind
of loyalty that still makes old men dip
their heads respectfully when they say
his name it was bad to drink too much
miss his turn into the driveway and run
over his own mailbox he was a man who
did the things more civilized men dream
they could do could beat one man half to
death for throwing a live snake at his
son they shot a large woman with a 410
shotgun when she tried to cut him with a
butcher knife to beat the hell out of to
worry some Georgia Highway patrolman and
threw them headfirst out the front door
of a beer joint called the maple on the
hill he was a man who led deputies on
long hapless chases across high lonesome
ridges and through briar choked bogs his
hands were so quickly snatched squirrels
from trees who hunted without regard to
seasons or quotas because how could a
game warden in Montgomery Atlanta know
if his babies were hungry he was just a
man I guess whose wings never quite fit
him right who built dozens of pretty
houses for depression-era wages and
never managed to build one for the
people he loved most who could not read
but always asked Ava to read him the
newspaper so he would not be ignorant
who held iron bars and babies in his
giant fists and called my mama Pooh boy
which makes me smile he died in the
spring of 1958 one year before I was
born
and I have never forgiven him for that
that's who they were that was the best I
could do
that was the best I could do to describe
them and it doesn't do either one of
them justice it's it's like drawing a
picture of him on the side of a barn and
thinking about him even though I never
saw him with my own eyes realizing just
how inadequate it is to try to tell you
what they were just ain't good enough to
do it that's the truth people who who
don't know anything about the deep south
and don't know anything about the
foothills of the Appalachians would
marvel at him they would just marvel at
him and the reason is because there just
ain't hardly an album left there just
aren't that many I'm left we did our
first signing at our first books on it
at a store in my home county and I think
we had 600 something people show up and
I knew a fourth of them's names and they
would come up and especially the older
folks would come up and they would say I
knew Charlie I knew him my knee buddy
was like one lady told me that she had
gone by and she had looked up on a roof
line and had seen him up there Ruth in
houses and she always remembered that
because sometimes she'd look up air and
he'd be drunk and he'd be weaving and
bobbing along the roof lining and it
happened it did happen it we actually
talked to some cousins who had seen it
happening he never fell off somehow and
we're really proud of that
but over and over and over again they
would come up and they would tell me
that they they remembered him and and
they would tell me that yeah he was he
was a pain sometimes and he was a
scoundrel and he was a good man and he
was a loving father and after a while
when too many people tell you that you
start to believe it I was proud they
came because I had to kind of take my
kinfolks worried about it for the book
and I was glad to see them backed up so
strongly he was not perfect we have a
strong circumstance of imperfection in
our family that I have shared for a long
time and I had to convince my aunt's my
Aunt Edna my aunt Gracie Juanita my aunt
Jo my mom - let me tell you all this
story including the warts and it was not
easy and finally I got them to to tell
me all of it
of course when his sons would start to
talk they were proud of every bad thing
he ever did you know they you know he
beat somebody up they go yeah I'll tell
you about it sit down you got our you
know it was fine but he was he was he
was not perfect but but I would have
given anything on earth to have shared
in that imperfection for a while let me
read you the first big fight Charlie and
I've ever had my aunt's will be mad at
me I'm gonna read it to you anyway
it's how long do Thanksgiving three
months two months they'll forgive me
between now and then
Ava met him at a box lunch auction
outside Gadsden Alabama when she was
barely 15 when a skinny boy and freshly
they washed over all stepped from the
crowd of bitters pointed to her and said
I got one dollar by God in the evening
they danced in the grass to a Fiddler's
and a banjo picker
and they ever told all the girls she was
going to marry that boy someday and she
did but to remind him that he was still
hers after the cotton rose age stir and
the babies came she had to flip a
painted woman named Blackie Lee maybe it
isn't quite right to say that she
whipped her to whip somebody down here
means that there was an altercation
between two people and somebody the ones
still standing one this wasn't that this
was a beaten
and it is not a moment that glimmers in
family history but of all the stories I
was told to their lives together this
one proves how Ava loved him
and hated him and which emotion won out
in the end
Charlie Bundren was what women here used
to call a Purdy man man with thick sandy
hair and blue eyes it looked like
something you would see on a rich
woman's bracelet his face was as thin
and spare as the rest of him and he had
a high tone chin in the air presence
like he had money but he never did his
head had never quite caught up with his
ears which were still too big for most
human beings but the women of his time
were not particular as to ears I suppose
he was also a man who was not adverse to
stopping off at the bootleggers now and
again and that was where he encountered
a travelin woman with crimson lipstick
and silk stockings named Blackie Lee
people call it her Blackie because of
her cold black hair and when she told my
granddaddy that she surely was parched
and tired and she sure would appreciate
a place to wash her clothes and rest a
spell he told her she was welcome in his
house they were living in North Georgia
at that time outside Rome even the five
children there was only James William
Edna Juanita and Margaret back then were
a few miles away working in new
morrison's cotton field Charlie always
took in strays dogs men and women who
needed a place there Blackie was a city
woman and pretty which set the stage for
mayhem and all might have gone unnoticed
luckily my to Worcester clothes set a
spell and then just moved along that was
all that she was after but we'll never
know we'll never know because she had
the misfortune to hang her stockings on
a viburnums clothesline
in front of God and everybody miles away
from there Ava was hunched over in
cotton field dragon sack her fingers and
thumbs on fire from the needle-sharp
stickers on cotton bolls Newt Morrison's
daughter cysts came up alongside of her
in the field one row over and lit the
fuse Ava said sis who had driven past
Ava and Charlie's house earlier that day
did you get you some silk stockings Ava
said no she had not what foolishness
and just picked on well sis said is your
sister grace visiting you no Ava said if
grace had come to visit she would have
written or sent word well said sis any
wonderful the power in just two words
three words three three
well said sis I drove past y'all's place
and seen some silk stockings on the line
and I thought they must have been
Grace's because she's the only one I
could think all that would have silk
stockings I even said well maybe it was
grace and picked on Grace had where'd a
rich man and had silk stockings and a
good car and may have come by to visit
just on a whim that must be it had to be
Edna
then only a little girl said her mama
just kept her back bowed and her face
down for a few more rows then jerk bolt
upright as if she had been stung by a
bee snatched the cotton sack from her
neck and flung it across to Rose then
she started walking and the children
puzzled hurried after her when she swung
into the yard some time later it was
almost dark and black Ely was on the
porch cooling herself
Ava stopped and drew a breath and just
looked at her for a moment measuring her
for her coughing then she stomped over
to the woodpile and picked up the axe
about that time it must have dawned on
Blackie Lee who this young woman was and
who these big eyed children were and she
ran inside put the latch down on the
door and began to speak to Jesus Ava
just stood there breathing hard her long
hair half in and half out of her doo rag
and announced that the woman could
either come on out open the door
take her beaten or take her beating
after Ava had hacked down her own door
and you might not want me in there she
said with an ax in my hand
Blackie Lee hysterical unlatch the door
and stepped back and Ava as she promised
dropped the ax and stepped inside she
might not have beat the woman quite so
bad if it had not been for the dish pan
it had dirty water in it from that
woman's clothes no one no one washed
their clothes in Ava's dish pan
Edna stood at the door peeking in listen
to her mama beat her all through the
house
she beat her out onto the porch beat her
out into the yard and beat her down to
the road beat her so hard that her hand
swelled up so big she couldn't fit them
in her apron-pocket then she grabbed
ahold of her with one hand and use the
other hand to flag down a car that was
coming and she jerked open that car door
and flung that woman in and told the man
driving that car to get her own out of
here and that man said yes ma'am
and drove off with Blackie Lee you know
I think about how fortunate that was
because what would have happened I mean
think about it this was in the
depression not many cars came down the
road my grandma would have been in the
Julia Tutwiler state prison for women if
that man had not been driving by at that
precise moment was Julia tell while our
open back then was it was it open way
back then it was well that was fortunate
it's a quality institution
nothing but the best for my grandmother
even the five children went back to Newt
Morrison's to spend the night Newt was
distant kin and Ava knew she was welcome
there but first she walked inside her
house and threw that dish pan out into
the yard as far as she could that might
be what tip Charlie off that things were
not going well that night he showed up
to take them home and Ava lit into him
so hard and so fast that Charlie lost
one of his shoes in the melee and had to
fight from an uneven platform which is
bad when you have what seems to be a
badger crawling and spitting around your
head they thought Edna said all the way
down the hall crashing hard into the
wall making a hellish racket and scaring
everybody in there to death children
screamed in dogs barked and Charlie just
kept on holler and over and over damn it
Ava quit finally they crashed on to bed
and into the room walk the old man Newt
barefoot one of his overall Gallus is
own and one off new thought that it was
Charlie who was beating his wife to
death instead of the other way around
and all he knew was that knew was that
this boy Charlie Kent or not had invaded
his home rattled the walls and
frightened his family knew stooped in
gray and gnarly was much too old
fistfight a man in his own home so he
reached into his overalls pocket fished
out his pocketknife and flicked out a
blade long enough to cut watermelon Ava
took one look at that knife and flung
her body across her husband to shield
him then she looked up at knew and when
she spoke there were spiders and broken
glass in her voice don't you touch him
she hissed
everybody has a moment like it and if
they never did they never did love
anybody truly people have lived a long
time say it so it must be so y'all are
being really nice to me and I feel
really guilty after Jake lied to you
where did you get a million books what
what are you reading
yeah it might be a million books they're
by Xerox did in their office and gave it
to friends you know what and you get you
folks know this when you write about
them and you talk about family the best
stories are always gonna you're gonna
miss him when I wrote this book I
thought I had the best possible stories
about Charlie and Haven their children
that anyone could possibly have and a
book came out and then everybody had 15
more cluding my entwine eita who you
know after the book is out says you know
I wish you could have got that that in
about Clem Ritter
and I said who was Clem Ritter and she
said daddy run over her head
I'm trying not to laugh a whole lot cuz
I was in Huntsville eyes not and I came
by the crystal on the way back and if
you ever yeah when you eat crystals
after midnight I'm sure I'll appear very
sophisticated talking about this but as
you know you ain't crystals after
midnight you cannot shake yourself too
hard
that hurt
I'm sure the crystal company's gonna
love me now
this body was built by crystals but she
told me I digress there for a minute
David sir said yeah yeah daddy run
overhead run over her head went in his
truck and I must have talked to her for
thirty five minutes before I realized
that Clem Ritter was a dog
and I'm not kidding including this
phrase yeah you know after that her head
was always real walk excited
and I had I had this image of this poor
woman walking around calhoun county
alabama a Floyd County Georgia with a
head and when she told me it was a dog I
was so happy I also should have
suspected something we said yeah you
know but she'd come running up into the
yard not long after he run over and also
should have been suspicious when she
said yeah after daddy went over he threw
her off in the ditch but I'm not very
smart there are many people that I got
to introduce y'all to in here that are
just wonderful colorful people let me
read you just a paragraph about my
great-grandfather Jimmy Jim who I knew
nothing about him before I started write
this book did not know his name
we say in this book that a lot of
southerners especially working
southerners blue-collar southerners the
ones down the hill from the veranda
don't always have a written history and
part of that is because a lot of them
did not read didn't write and so once
they're gone they're gone unless the old
people will tell you about him and in
this case it was my cousin called back
home who who told me gave me a picture
of my great-grandfather it's just what
he looked like
his temper was hot his Birds blood and
his eyes seemed to burn even in
photographs he had a hook nose and thick
brown moustaches I wore overalls with a
black suit coat with a black suit coat
over them and was known to carry a
little 22 pistol on his coat
he largely disregarded any laws or
influence outside his own will and some
people do not like to look him dead in
the eye because it made him feel weak
quote he was dark headed and was scared
and wasn't scared of the devil said
Claude Bundren who grew up in Jimmy
Jim's long dark shadow he always drank
and done just what he wanted and I was
not really much point in reading you
know who that man is somehow have you
bumped into him somehow he probably
raised by tough old men like that at the
risk of running people out of the room
I'll read you the story of one of the
many acts of violence attributed to Jim
and Jim and our family we refer to it
only as the finger any of you with weak
stomachs or maybe the Lutheran's
not one he's on out of here now it
happened when Charlie was still a boy
around 1915 at a spot in Calhoun County
called the mill branch I didn't really
mean to make fun of the Lutheran's
really little bit it's not it's not bad
a beautiful clear water spraying where
the hard drinkers gathered in the cool
of the evening to swap lies and trade
dogs and cut each other up a little bit
to settle differences rich men would
have dueled and said the killing was
over honor poor men just cut and anger
and sometimes there was honor in it and
sometimes a man holding the bloody knife
because mine befuddle from whiskey just
went home and told his wife he reckoned
the sheriff would be by directly wasn't
always a killing sometimes man we just
beat on each other until their fists
bled not like in Hollywood but
scrambling around on their hands and
feet in the gravel eye gouging cuss and
mean and wicked and the glow from the
massive popping campfires there were so
many that the mill branch passed into
legend
old drunks are still drawn to the place
and that now and then you'll pass by
there and see one of them sitting
quietly in his car sipping from a can
wrapped in a brown paper bag
remembering that particular night is the
mule stood tied to the oak trees and the
whiskey cooled in the spring one of the
men insulted my great-grandfather or my
great-grandfather imagined he did he
might have just been too drunk to be
sure but he called the man a son of a
[ __ ] anyway and that's usually enough
down here to get a good fight started
the man was drinking too which would
have made it a fair fight if Jimmy Jim
had known how to fight fair which he
didn't they came together inside a
yelling ring of onlookers and it was by
most accounts a mean and frightful
battle they landed leaks it might have
killed sober men kicked it shins and
stomped it toes and it is certain took
the Savior's name in vain over and over
again the man he was fighting a bigger
man caught at Jimmy Jim's face and
finally got his hands on my
great-granddad his throat and began with
all the strength in his arms and fingers
to choke the life out of him
I couldn't get loose I couldn't break
his hole Jimmy Jim told vehicle loader I
believe he'd have killed me
but a man who swings an axe all day has
to have arms like iron and fingers like
rivets and Jimmy Jim slowly prized one
of the man's fingers from his throat
then another and another
then the man hooked one of his fingers
maybe two inside Jimmy Jim's cheek and
just hauled back on it tearing into
flesh making Jim howl and agony man was
trying to rip his cheek out so Jim and
Jim did what he had to do he bit off one
of the man's fingers at the second joint
it was not a clean bite I'll spare you
all the particulars the man started to
wail to my great-granddaddy spit and
that was by God that he just stood there
were blood running down his mouth and
grinned as the man whimpering slumped
down to the ground holding his bloody
hand history is unclear as to which
finger it was it was too big to be the
pinky everyone agrees or from which hand
it was nod but we know precisely what
happened to it
just wonder if this will makes these fan
but we know precisely what happened to
it Jimmy Jim took the finger home in the
pocket of his overalls and put it on the
mantel his wife Maddy a gentle person
left the dreadful thing there on the
mantel until Jimmy Jim sobered up then
threw it out in the yard where it was
apparently snatched up by a chicken I'm
gonna I'm gonna regret that
there's nothing I'm so amused by this
myself it's just that I just saw my
little bit of literary career I have
passing by just it's just just easing
right on behind there's nothing I can do
about it I was going to try to flip
through here and find y'all a story that
was gentler and nicer and sweeter but
I'm having a hard time let me read you a
story that captures my grandma Ava
perfectly this is chapter six it's
called in the wild on loose denial of
the kusa and they had a wild rivers in
the 1920s the man had been drinking the
evening that Jeff Baker got stabbed and
bled clean through the brown sugar his
hot blood melting it turning it into
treacle just as fast as Newt Morrison
and mr. Hugh Sanders could pack it in
his wounds Jeff moaned and trembled and
the men praise God that Jeff had had so
much good whiskey in him because surely
that numbed his pain and prepared his
soul is in the summer not long after
they were Wed on the river not far from
Newt Morrison's farm Newt mr. Hugh
Charlie Jeff and some other men had
walked down the river to a still to have
a taste
the women AVA news daughter Seth and
some others sat on a wide porch visiting
as soon as the men were pretty well
stone blind Jeff a big man in his 20s
who had no visible means of support was
also rumored to be unpacking coop he
visited late at night got into a
fistfight with a man about as big as his
leg Jeff beaten him into a bloody heap
on the ground
but the little man was a gamer and he
kept on coming finally the small man
staggered to his feet for what all the
men there hoped would be the last time
and Jeff it was not an evil man at heart
way to fist at him to just stay away
turned his back somewhere in his clothes
little man found
and he jumped on Jeff's back and snaked
one arm hard around his throat then he
just started stabbing reaching over to
plunge the blade into Jeff's side and
chest the knife like a windmill flinging
blood Geoff was screaming and staggering
the other men they might have acted
faster if they don't all been so drunk
pulled the tiny man off him and flung
him aside and Jeff slumped face-first in
the dirt
he's killed Newt said is the little man
ran off through the bushes but the wound
still pump blood the men all grabbed an
arm or leg and staggered from the weight
of the man in fact they were still say
I'm drunk all the way back to newts
house newt called for brown sugar
everyone knew that if you packed a wound
with enough brown sugar it would cloth
the blood and stop a man from bleeding
to death but as fast as they could take
it on the blood from the stab wounds
washed it away until Newton mr. Hugh
were bloody up to their elbows and most
of the people had begun to pray mr. Hugh
searched his mind for a scripture that
could save the man just because a man is
drunk does not mean he cannot speak to
the Lord
does anybody know that goddamn Bible
verse he shouted this son of a [ __ ] is
bleeding to death which in several
people asked Ezekiel he yelled Ava who
hated any violence that she was not
directly involved in had stood trembling
but now she stepped smartly forward as
if called from on high knelt at the
man's side and when I passed by the and
see the polluted in thine own blood she
quoted I said unto thee when thou wast
in thy blood live ye I said unto thee
when I was in my blood live Battin mr.
Hugh said looking at Aven something
close to all chapter 16 a verse said mr.
Hugh said that saying like in verse 6
they ever said it would be a grand story
if the blood had ceased to flow right
then at that precise moment but it
didn't get somehow either through the
will of God or the coagulating
properties of brown sugar
the wounds soon stopped pouring and
began to seep slowly
of course by the end he was bled almost
white they figured there was no need to
take him to a doctor and when he came to
he told him no I I reckon I'll just lay
here and die
he paid see us and newts other children
a nickel a day to brush the flies off
him and he waited to die for a long long
time finally after a few days Newt told
him that if he wasn't going to die he
sure did won't his porch back and Jeff
got up and walked on down the road
I wanted to hit y'all one with a happy
ending when we're at the our first
signing I had a very very funny thing
happened all the people rushed when when
he came to him sign books
they went straight to my mom and her
sisters and had them sign the book and I
was just kind of sitting there and when
by the time I got it there was a line of
signatures on the title page
William Bunn Juanita Fair
Edna Saunders Margaret Bragg Jo couch
it's probably best thing you ever
happened to me last night it's real good
night and I couldn't read with him any
of these stories because they've got mad
at me but they're at home and they might
not be watching c-span they probably
will be and I probably am in bad trouble
a lot of people wondered why Ava who was
from a a good family outside Gadsden
Alabama why she put up with Charlie why
she why she didn't just go away and the
answer I think is is in a chapter that I
wrote I'll flip disconcertingly through
here well I try to find it about her
sister grace we mentioned grace earlier
when I was learning to when I first did
my first book I was learning how to do
all this stuff the people at the
publishing house told me that you should
not flip disconcertingly through your
book in front of a large group of people
yeah which is fine except how in the
hell do you get a book to go for one
place to another without flipping listen
this explains why my grandmom stayed
with my granddaddy all those years
grace smoked slim cigarettes drank like
a man and wore makeup and when she
rumbled down carpenters laying in her
big car people's head swiveled to follow
her because it was a fine automobile and
because grace was pretty fine herself
sitting in it grace visited Ava a good
bit when her older sister lived on the
Alabama side when she came it was like a
big movie star had come to town Grace
was a tiny beautiful woman who went to
the beauty shop when she wanted to who
dressed in clothes from the department
stores and Gadsden Birmingham and
Atlanta other women wore bonnets Grace
had store-bought hats with lace that
droop mysteriously over her eyes
hats with silken roses and even tiny red
birds with real feathers sewn into them
and when she stuck her foot out of the
car to get out there was a high-heeled
on it when they were grown James and
Williams used to take her to town and
pretend she was their girlfriend to make
their sweethearts jealous she was 40 by
the end she looked 25 and she had
eyelashes like bat wings and when she
fluttered them it just did something to
men's in science grace had married a
Greek named jorge montes and they ran a
cafe in Birmingham and later in a Talon
near Gadsden they were well off he
employed 20 people at one time and they
went to Florida to see the ocean or
orange groves and alligators they sent
postcards Ava put them in the corners of
the mirror so she could look at them
it was the life Ava could have had maybe
the life she was raised to have instead
she sat in another rented house with
another baby to feed worried over with
two grown sons a teenage daughter and
two more little girls pulling at her
dress all day every day it was not so
obvious most days until grace came and
they sat on the porch or in the kitchen
coffee cups in their hands
Gracie's hands were still smooth Ava
scarred from the cotton bolls had always
managed to go
her nails burned pink in places from
Scott hot skillet handles look more like
a man's addresses were made from flour
sacks and feed sacks and she picked
cotton in them because it wasn't
ladylike to pick cotton in pants and
wasn't even her damn cotton she wore her
hair like the black women at the time
bound up in a scarf like a turban to
keep it out of her eyes when she did
stoop labor and sewing and one day she
unwrapped it and found that this shiny
inky black was now cut with white
strands as if by some evil hex and she
cried and she cried and there was not
one thing that Charlie could say she did
not have a wedding ring or even a simple
gold band while she still had about a
hundred cheap dime-store purses she
didn't have anything to put in them
except newspaper clippings of all those
things she found interesting but would
never do or see cut out pictures of Hank
Williams from discarded magazines things
like that she had been a mama a mama in
a manual labor or her whole life and her
husband was not going to lift her out of
it and in fact had never promised that
he would Charlie Bunim didn't have one
pair of overall she had not had to
stitch and he smelled like tar and snuff
and he drank his moonshine when it
pleased him and he acted a fool and ran
over the mailbox and fought the deputies
and brought home Hermits she could have
hated her life but what she always said
if she had married a dull man
oh it was true that she told him to go
to hell more times than she could count
and it was true she told him to get his
raggedy behind out of her house before
she killed him to take his hermits with
him I mean no one can remember one time
in all those years and she told him to
shut up there was never a time not one
time that he came in from work sat down
at the kitchen table and had nothing to
say what a by God tragedy that would
have been so when grace climbed back in
her car careful not to snag her
stockings
Ava watched from the porch little girls
clutching at her dress and waved goodbye
what's why Eva put up with him and why
about that time she will Blackie Lee any
woman can appreciate a pretty man but
not every woman can appreciate a talking
one I think that pretty much explains
I think what I'm going to do if it's
alright with you folks I'm going to
probably read you just a little bit more
if that's alright and then we'll have
some questions and we'll keep answering
them as long as we're here or until
somebody stands up and tells me to shut
up which comes in varying stages
depending on where you are I I guess if
I had to pick if I had to pick one place
in this book that really kind of shows
the decency and the strength of
character of my granddaddy it would be
the story of Jesse who declines
I begin this chapter with a quote from
my aunt Gracie Juanita who I said what
did he look like and she answered let's
put it this way hon a woman wouldn't run
herself to death going after him on the
river among the dragons that slumbered
in the deep caves along its banks and
the mysterious things that called down
from the trees was a gremlin
his name was Jesse Klein's but everyone
just called him Hootie he was a dusty
scrawny man about five feet high and his
boot heels and would have weighed less
than a hundred pounds if his trouser
pockets had not always been filled with
silver dimes just Don's he had a face
like a pickaxe his nose was long and a
hook it and pointy on the end like he
bought it at the dollar store and tied
it on his face with a string and it
curved all the way down past his lips I
would not have believed it if the people
telling me his story had not raised
their right hand to God
he had beady eyes set in close on his
nose and if he had one tooth in his head
it would have died of loneliness he
always smelled like wood smoking bait he
could go into our days without saying a
word and when he did talk his voice was
Reedy in high he always wore an old army
uniform but he had never been in the
army he just liked the suit his breeches
had holes in the many holes and he wore
red long handle underwear which was
plain to see he wore a long build
fisherman's cap the kind the rich men
wore in their yachts on saltwater and it
had a leaping Blue Marlin stenciled on
the crown hoody probably never saw a
more Lynne or saw an ocean for that
matter but he loved that hat when he
wore it out actually when it just rotted
off his head he got a felt slouch hat
like the kind of Jimmy Cagney wore he
wore discarded shoes and cut holes in
them that when they were too tight or
just for ventilation
daddy wore holes in his shoes said
Juanito hoody just cut holes in his
he live down on the river and a tiny
Shack and no one seemed to know if he
owned it had once owned it or just
squatted there he had always been there
living on fish and whisky trading one
for the other
his only luxury was potted meat you know
I read that some places they have no
idea what the hell I'm talking about by
show of hands how many of you have ever
eaten potted meat
how many of those of you that did not
raise your hands are lying because
you're afraid somebody will see you on
TV
but see we got conversation started
about potted meat it's gonna take a lot
they called him Hootie because he liked
to talk to the owls the woods on the
river were full of owls they hunted the
banks for rats ground squirrels
chipmunks and just about anything else
he moved and the cause they gave really
did sound like hoot but trembling like
what you might imagine a ghost would
sound like he could answer them and it
sounded just the same people would see
him on the bank working his trot lines
or traps and pointed him and either
laugh or stare but who they only looked
like a gremlin it was too harmless for
that too good-natured he was more like
an elf he wasn't even a real hermit
Hermits don't get lonely hoody had
Charlie first saw hoody when he was
fishing the river near his Shack he
waved at the little man dude he just
stood there
Charlie waved again who he stuck his
hand up in the air as if surprised that
it didn't hurt Charlie walked up the
riverbank and who'd he stood there
acting like he wanted to run Charlie
looked him up and down well Charlie said
you sure had pretty are you son
hoody shook his head Charlie said I got
some biscuit if you want something Couty
nodded friendships get started on a lot
less than that
to Charlie he was not a gnome or an
outcast just another person to tell
tales to to catch fish with another man
who preferred campfire to the glare of
electric light in that moment hoody
followed him around like a new puppy
Charlie who could talk enough for any
two men did not mind the fact that hoody
just smiled listening it was not prone
to interrupt he was not [ __ ] just
quiet and a little bit slow but people
thought it he wasn't right because he
would not always answer them when they
spoke to him he was just shy a kingly
shy life had probably made him that way
made him live in his own head he could
never lived in town there were a lot of
men on the river then who couldn't have
lived in
Charlie was almost one of them but he
was just too lonely on the river for a
man who wanted friends a wife and an
ever growing number of babies crawling
around him on the floor so instead of
being a place he lived in it was a place
he went to to get away from life for a
while and who he was always there two
men one so tall one so small built fires
and past a mason jar hooch back and
forth and cook fish over the fire on
thin pieces of steel with the help of
Charlie's sons they dug mussels from the
sandbars and used them to bake their
lines and snatched the giant cats from
the eddies and through it all Charlie
talked I like to hear you talk mr.
Charlie hoody said once out of the blue
well son Charlie said we are both
fortunate Charlie always called him son
even though hoody was probably 20 years
older than him somehow just seemed right
it went on that way for about a year
Charlie saw him every month or so always
on the river some people would have said
he was mysterious which is just a fancy
way of saying he was lied about there
were more lies told about Jesse who
declines than any man on the river and
it almost killed him in time as word of
the little Hermits presents leaked out
the stories came some people said hoody
was a wounded hero from the great war
who had been horribly mutilated only
that would explain his appearance
because nobody's born that ugly another
said he was a circus performer who had
committed some terrible crime under the
big top batter he fell off the circus
train as it passed through North Georgia
some said he had escaped from a loony
house and some said he'd robbed a bank
up north in Chicago maybe or Indiana
that all the other members of his gang
had been gunned down hoody they say it
had escaped with thousands and silver
dollars and some said he'd robbed
oh no I read that paragraph talk about
being slow
they said he came here to this isolated
place to lay low no one seemed to mind
that he'd been laying low there for
about thirty years and that he'd hidden
the money on the river some people
people even said he had buried the money
all around his shack in mason jars and
he'd dug it up every now and then to
feel it run through his fingers if the
stories have been true Jesse Klein's
would have been the most famous man on
the state line instead there was just
enough rumor just enough myth to draw
people to him and many of them were bad
the river was still a lawless place then
one night a group of men came to Hudy
Shack and told him they wanted his money
and they commenced to beat him they
passed the basel and beat him for a long
long time it became a ritual every now
and then a group of drunks would catch
him in his bed and make a game out of it
some people are just a waste of human
skin these people were that kind
sometimes they just beat him a little
slap him his jobs back and forth and
sometimes they beat him pretty bad
putting their boot Hills to him no one
knows why he did not pack his few
pitiful belongings and Ron it maybe he
had no place to go but even this was
better than how he had lived before he
drifted here one day Charlie came and he
saw what the river trash had done to
hoody both his eyes were blacked his
lips were split and he was still
bleeding from his mouth internal II
asked hootie-hoo beaten him so badly who
he refused to answer
Charlie sat with him all day and that
night he layed hoody down on his cot and
walked down to his car to fetch his
roofing hatchet he waited on the stoop
of the shack all night his hatchet in
his right hand hoping but nobody came
the next morning you told hoody to pack
up his clothes and come with him you
can't stay here and I got to work and I
can't stay with you he told hoody
he took him home to their little place
in the country outside Rome what you
doing with him Eve I asked when he saw
hoody sitting on the porch he's going to
stay with us for a while Charlie said
and he explained what had happened how
the river trash had a booze abused him
we barely got enough for us I ever said
we'll have enough Charlie said Ava who
considered it a point of pride that she
would go to her grave without ever
letting anyone have the last word on
anything said she reckoned it would be
fine for a while it would be years
before Charlie found out who'd beaten
his friend and the anger should have
cooled by then it should have there is a
conclusion to this that appears later in
the book it was one of the most
satisfying things I've ever written it
involved a small amount of violence this
chapter he answered Judy help Charlie
works sometimes for decent wages he ate
at their table and was treated like
family
I never remember when he wasn't here one
ADA said sometimes their friends would
ask them who the funny-looking little
man was and they always said the same
thing
that's who tea daddy got him off the
river why the other children always say
I have a lot more fun talking with y'all
and talking at you so won't we take some
questions for a while I might leave read
just a little bit more later on but or
anything out there any questions at all
anybody
usually there's a PD question anything
like that
somebody's got to raise their damn hand
we're on TV
yes ma'am oh it's impossible I marry
down to a few she asked me who my
favorite author was and there's a
there's a meticulous timing to this that
I just stomped all over you see there's
a boom man here and he's going to stick
the boom at you when you ask a question
and I forgot my fate I guess my
favourites are are probably a favorite
book I guess of all time would either be
Robert Penn Warren Saul the King's Men
or Larry McMurtry's Lonesome Dove I was
stranded in Clearwater Florida starting
a new job and I didn't have a paycheck
for a few weeks and I was living on
banana sandwiches and tomato sandwiches
and water a pop jar of mayonnaise was my
only luxury and oh yeah it was white
bread we
that's like asking me if I'm large and
and I my TV was marooned in Anniston
Alabama and I had no entertainment but I
had a paperback copy of Lonesome Dove
and I read Lonesome Dove two times back
to back and was reading it a third time
when my TV finally got there and I have
read it since then because I don't think
anybody makes people stand up and walk
and talk like that
patcon oil would be in that group
certainly because he just writes so well
about family and about and quite frankly
about pain Willie Morris was probably
the sweetest user of language I have
ever seen
Eudora Welty wrote with grit you know
you know of the people that are that I
have read lately Cormac McCarthy anybody
ever read blood meridian could not not
be disturbed my great book I love James
Lee Burke I always leave out really good
people you know when when I started
stand up here talking like this now hit
myself in the head later on but I like
Southern writers not I don't want to be
a cliche but I really like him a lot and
Toni Morrison's beloved you know it's
such a great book I just love to read
bad thing about being working for a
newspaper is you know you can either
work for a newspaper you can read
because you don't have time to do both
and it's fun I wish I could read more
but that does that sound like that's a
pretty good list
I liked Amy Tan's stuff a lot and when I
was younger a lot younger I you know is
probably a lot of you you know you just
escaped not that there's anything bad
where you are but you know you can go a
long way you can go all the way to Asia
with James Clavell you know yeah there's
there's a ton of places you can go with
a good book and and I used to just
ruse with them anybody else let's go
here and then here
do you ever fight a job make me stand
out here like an idiot well you write so
well nonfiction do you ever plan to try
fiction well yeah yeah I mean I'd like
to I'd like to do it and I and I will do
it someday because every even people
never thought about writing a word in
their life want to write a novel before
they die but there were just so many
great stories to tell from from family
that were right there I think if they
had not been right there if they had not
been just waiting for me then you know I
probably would have started writing a
novel years ago but the truth is they're
they're just you know they're just
slapping you up you know in the face
they're so good and and I just wanted to
do that shouting I did shouting because
you know I wanted to honor my mother and
after what Jake said earlier I'm not
that nice a guy I'm not but I wanted to
honor her with that book and we did that
we got it done this one again was very
selfish on my part but yeah I mean I'd
love to oh yeah I mean that'd be fun you
know I could just take I can take real
life people in Alabama and write a great
you know we could just we could just
start with politicians you we could just
and yeah we wouldn't even have to be
even have to make anything up just
change all the names and I mean who
could invent who can invent our leaders
I'm gonna just think about that for a
minute but but now I'd love to you know
if I do one though it will be it'll be
you know it'll be about people from the
foothills of the Appalachians and it
will be it'll be written I hope with the
same love that these were written but it
would just be just a great fun thing to
do and and I don't want to write another
story about family on time a very very
old man and probably not even then you
know I think I've written the best of my
family and and and and I was blessed
that they were interesting you know if
they had not been interesting I wouldn't
have written it it then but they were
interesting and that's why that's why I
did these this way
thank that's a good question thank you
let's go let's go over here on this side
whoever's got the there we go
so you have to discipline yourself to
rider is there something that you just I
think anybody that knows me knows I've
never disciplined myself in anything I
have friends sitting out there they I
know they're people I here have known me
for you know I'm 42 they've known me
since I was you know 14 I've never done
anything with any particular structure
outline or guidance but I think writing
it you know I don't have to tell you all
this is hard and I I've worked for
newspaper supposed to my life you know
you don't get to say you know I would
have loved to got that story done but
Muse just one known me today
I don't think they like it hold on and
so the books that I've written I wrote
in my spare time and and you have to be
disciplined as far as just getting it
done you have to sit down and start
doing it but it was the deadlines that
gave me the discipline and they wouldnt
have anything to do with me I've heard
some great stories about how people
write and why they write and when they
write and there's a great story and I'm
stealing it from somebody else about a
fella who who who when he would sit down
to write a story just for he'd sit down
to write he'd drink like one of them big
Oh half gallon things of Diet Coke or
something like that then he built
himself into his chair by god that's
discipline and he wouldn't get up till
he's done so uh so I've never been that
disciplined about anything just to give
you some idea you know I have a little
house in New Orleans and uh when I was a
little kid I my brother Sam tells this
lie about me and it's not true he says
that when I would eat fried chicken so
fast that I would not want to get up to
go back to the kitchen to get or take
the bones away but I like to have my
plate mostly clean so I could get at it
better and he said that I would throw
the chicken bones over my shoulder
behind the couch now that is a damn
dirty lie
that never happened but every now and
then I will pull my couch away from the
wall to clean and there will be a ho ho
wrapper you know or every now and then
of somehow potato chips make their way
back there I'm not real sure how that is
but to know I you know I right but to
get it done and because I love it and uh
but mostly it's somebody else's
discipline that does it for me thank God
for it
let's go let's go here and then here
y'all help me remember okay cuz I how
was your mom doing and does she still
live in Jacksonville there and does she
get to travel with you well let's put it
this way yeah oh yeah she went down at
Oxford it was the fist 15 minutes from
home she she worried the whole time
house is going to burn down dogs are
going to starve to death you know but
mama mama is doing pretty good
considering many times that you know
that she's been hammered by life she is
doing real well and she is getting you
know she's my mom and I love her but the
older she gets that stubbornness and
toughness and strength of character is
beginning to fade a little more toward
obstinance
she has oh no no Oxford is as close to
getting out of Calhoun County as she's
gotten a long time and that's only
because it's near the county line
but mama to give you an idea of just how
hard it is to get her to do anything
like that
she had a little place a little blemish
come up on her nose and I'm really
worried about it and I said my god mama
you and you got to go to the doctor you
need to get it looked at
she's old baby I will and you know six
months later Oh baby I will and I begged
her and I begged her and I begged her
and I called my aunts who are the only
people that seem to have any influence
over her and said mommy you need really
y'all got to take her somewhere and and
then they said Oh baby we will so I came
home not too long ago and I looked at
her and it was gone and I was just I
cannot tell you how happy you know I was
just you know it should not have been a
big thing but I was just so happy and I
and I I said might thank you so much I
mean you know thank you she said honey
it wasn't nothing let's talk to my
brother Sam later that day and I said
Sam did you see mama had that thing
taking off her he said no she didn't
she's walking through the house the
other day and it just fell off
any of you who think I might be
exaggerating can call my brother Sam
he's in the phone book so now she
doesn't travel with me she to get my mom
out of Calhoun County to get her out of
the Nesbitt Lake Road area where she
lives would require a bulldozer and
several sticks of dynamite the fact that
she went to the book signing thrilled me
to death I was so happy and he made
everybody else happy tell me it was it
was fantastic and she she had no idea
though how what would happen when people
asked her to sign the book and and she
started signing and she actually wrote
legibly and and she was very ashamed of
me she said this more than once you look
at my signature and go Ricky you ain't
no doctor
we had another one over here somewhere
let's let's go here and then we'll work
the our way around back y'all help me
I'll help me remember okay New Orleans
is my home so I'm curious to know if
it's gotten its hooks into you enough
yet that you're thinking about writing
in New Orleans I'm not no I'm not
writing I'm gonna write it like I write
about New Orleans sometimes for the
paper but I'm not ever gonna I'm not
never gonna do it I don't think because
first of all it's a you know it's a
complicated and fascinating place but
it's not my place and I live there
because I love it and because they let
me live there but I'm a tourist with a
water bill I mean I know I am I love it
I have made a I've made a ton of new
friends there that I'm gonna keep the
rest of my life and I don't love it for
the reasons a lot of people love it I
mean I I do love it for the fact it's
got the best food on earth outside of my
mama's kitchen but it's it's really just
a magical strange beautiful place and
it's the people can talk about a broken
water main and you have more fun talking
to them about a broken water main then
you would you know anything else and I
love the music and I love the fact that
it's just I always wanted to be when I
was a kid I want to be an architect and
I actually took drafting in school and
did real good at it until the we started
doing circles and straight lines and and
those of you who have ever done that
knows that's when you have to have the
math I don't have any math but New
Orleans you can just walk down the
street and see a house that working
people live in and it'll be a thing of
beauty
a beautiful you know wood frame house
and I just really like being there and
and I you know I I like that River and I
still like real wild about eating the
crawfish hole I realize that that makes
me you know I'm not all about guard and
uh because you know people who live
there just do it so easy and quick you
know but but it's also considered real
cool to be able to do it if you're an
outsider and I'm sorry but it seems like
a whole lot of work to me I mean a
chicken
chickens easy but you know it's too much
work for that much meat y'all help y'all
help me let's do this then we'll go here
and back there okay well I'm gonna try
not to run the boom man to death y'all
help me remember yes there's a
photograph that I haven't been able to
read the book but at least look at the
photographs are good don't say but why
is Charlie showing off that mall head
can't fish any worth that mall head
you don't eat those things oh yes you do
maybe not on your side of town
I'm looking for the photograph so that's
you know the truth is he might not have
eaten it he might just have been showing
off but they ate everything and they
used to got the Guntersville and catch
those big cats on you know on right
right and they would use them for uh
they'd use my granddaddy had a pool cue
with a snag hook on the end of it and
they would just lean over and you know
and trail it through the water it wasn't
exactly the most sporting way to go
fishing but then again he also did the
the you know if he really needed fish he
would take the crank telephone you know
you know have you seen those have you
ever used one of them Oh
or bajar dynamite but but he he would he
would take a yes but he would take the
crank telephone and he would drop the
line in the wire and he'd crank the
crank real hard so they got a charge
built up uh-huh
would you just like to come up here
you know there is there is nothing worse
than talking about fish and having there
be a fisherman in the group no no I know
exactly what you mean but he would he
would do he fish from two car hoods
welded together so he might have shocked
himself several times in the process but
but he listened here
he used to they would this is one of
those things I loved writing about they
would go up and they would catch a lot
of catfish and they would bring him home
and they would cook them with gravy
which I've never heard of you know they
make white milk gravy with a catfish and
apparently it was pretty good and they
would have big fish fries and they would
sit and they would talk and they were
talking they talked until after it was
dark and I couldn't see each other and
then they just talked to the dark you
know and I we had a few of those when I
was a kid but I would have loved to have
been there and listened to what they
said you know yeah I know you got
another question going if Miss Ava had a
kill Blackie Lee they was in Georgia
that she would have gone to
Milledgeville not no no they would have
fled to Alabama
and and you assumed that she would not
have dragged her body across the state
line let's go I think this lady right
here had a question then we're going to
go back there y'all help me remember yes
yes ma'am that's a long time ago I would
have given anything on earth to have
been smart enough to have written down
exactly what was said by like for
instance my Uncle Henry by my aunt
Plumer you know people they're gone that
would give anything I wonder if I was
that bright but I was just I was too
concerned with you know I wasn't
concerned with anything I was I was I
just I just wasn't smart enough I would
have loved to have done it it would have
been a really nice thing to done but I I
just never did I wish I'd written it
down let's go back here that lady's had
her hand up for a while my question a
lot of the stories that you write for
the paper about the end of something or
the passing of something or or of loss
and I wanted to know is that what they
like for you to write or is it something
that you're just really good at doing I
think that I think that you don't we
were talking about that earlier tonight
you know you
we got a cliche in a business you know
you don't write about the plane when it
lands safely you know and and to me the
most interesting and compelling stories
are often in the saddest ones and here
lately I have written an awful lot about
the passing of eras and I think because
we think they're important I wrote about
the closing of a cotton mill in my
hometown and that's two hundred people
in a small town who have no work
overnight and as two hundred people who
have done this most of their life most
of them and they've given their fingers
and more to it and they've given you
know their lungs to it and then it just
goes away
that's that's the story that's the news
first
right
well the blues musicians was when you
talk about selfish I love the blues and
I knew that if I went and did this story
that I would get to sit in the living
rooms a several old man who played the
blues and I would get to sit there and
they would play their guitars for me and
I would sit there and I'd listen to him
so at wooden was stealing that was I
should have not eaten Tevan filed an
expense report that was just that one
was just stealing but I want I listen to
a man named C Dale Davis who was struck
with polio as a young man and he played
the guitar by putting it in his lap
upside down and courting it with a
butter knife and he would slide he put
wedged the butter knife between his
hands this was about all the mobility he
had he'd wedged the butter knife in and
he would cord and he had this beautiful
strong voice and he played these
haunting sad songs and I was just you
know I mean I guess I was in him
something pretty close to rapture it was
just beautiful so pretty and then he
read it back and saying if you like fat
women go on down to Fort something
Arkansas because we got more fat women
there than any place you ever saw
so I know it that one was stealin the
caterer was funny because the Cajuns
were you know they had such a great
sense of humor about it a census story
had shown that instead of there being
something like four hundred thousand
Cajuns there's only 40 thousand Cajuns
which means nine out of ten Cajuns is
gone and and that's that was inaccurate
Anna and I would go there and they were
just great about it they'd say like nah
I'm here and it was fine
they had a great sense of humor about it
let's go over here how you doing when
did you first know that you wanted to be
a writer and when did you know that you
could write professionally do you
remember that day that I pulled up into
your yard on my Honda 100 motorcycle and
the chain came off and I was standing
there that was that moment of southern
angst that that just made me feel like I
could be creative at some point in the
future but I I don't know you know I
think I knew I grew up with and I've
said this before but I grew up at the at
the feet but the best storytellers that
have ever been and and I hope that
doesn't sound arrogant but but but they
are the best you know my uncle's could
tell your story and just make you just
you know creep closer and closer and
closer to them until you were under
their feet
they you know they would tell stories
like my daddy's brothers you know we're
always in trouble they were the ones
that you know we may have my mama Ryan
buy the Calhoun County Jail once I'm
nothing but the Jacksonville jail once
and my mama said your daddy and all his
brothers was in there once all on the
same day
and I said well my god what were then
there for and mama said they's in there
for brawling and I said well who were
they brawling and she said each other
and uh and they could tell you a story
and they would sit out on the course and
they would they would they would smoke
roll and smoke cigarettes and they would
they would they could make you feel the
wind from a fist that barely missed
their head they could make you hear the
chains rattling in the deputy's pocket
as he chased them you know they they
were just the best there is and my mom
and her sisters are great storytellers
might want need a man and they're
they're you know wonderful storytellers
and my aunt Joe is a great storyteller
my mom once you get a rollin has this
great sense of irony and its really good
but you know they I knew I knew how to
tell one but transferring that into
writing is hard telling a story is is
free and fun writing one can be like
digging taters I mean it can be really
hard you know I mean anybody's against
ever tried to write and sit down and
felt that throbbing in their head and
your legs no go numb or maybe that's
just a condition of my high blood
pressure but you know it's writing is
hard telling is is easy I think I was
probably in my late in my early 20s I'd
already had been working for newspapers
so I finally figured out that the two
could come together and you could you
know what I mean
you could do one I kind of doing it the
way you had always heard to tell a story
but I'm still trying to figure it out
and that's the truth I wish I knew
let's go right here and then right there
okay y'all help me remember yes ma'am
last summer when we spoke with you in
Homewood and you spoke about this book
now you had mentioned that the title was
going to be on a bluebird day they
saying that your grandfather had had I
was wondering why the time was changed
and the second part is do you miss Miami
the first part is easier to answer my
the title was actually going to be that
something my brother Sam had said and
then something that had been passed down
from the old men like my grandfather and
if you're fishing the the Bertha's comes
from I'll explain it to folks when
you're fishing and the sky is perfectly
clear and the Sun is overhead the fish
see and you ain't going to catch many
and I had out fished my brother Sam for
the first time in my miserable life and
I was so proud and I was dancing around
him all I wanted to and I had caught no
fish and I'd called about six and uh and
he just sort of threw the fishing rods
in the back of the the truck and said
Rikki I was fishing for the big fish
you might enjoy this exactly right and
uh and he said and everybody knows that
the big fish won't buy it on a bluebird
day and I wanted to throw a rock at him
because and this is in the introduction
of the book because on the one day in my
life that I out fish my brother he is
spouting poetry and doing greater
literature than I probably ever read and
I just got mad but he made me think and
again I wrote this in the introduction
you know where do those phrases come
from and I won't need the title of the
book to be the fish won't buy it on a
bluebird day they gently explained to me
that no way in hell was that going to
happen cause one it wouldn't fit down
the spine of the book and the words
would be too small and it would confuse
people or it would make them think it
was about fishing and that the opening
chapter title had been Ava's man and I
was looking at it and I thought well
they can't say it's too long can they
and now that I thought about it I don't
can't think about it is anything except
Davis man and it also does honor to my
grand mom cuz the book is mostly about
Charlie and she deserved more than that
and the failure of the book is not to
have given her more than that and I you
know I so uh Ava's man is is only fair
don't miss Miami I do miss Miami I miss
Miami every time I go back and I look
out over that water and I think how
beautiful it is and I and I miss it
every time I get a real bad yearning for
a ham croqueta and I miss it you know
when I
I miss it when I'm away from it like you
miss all things that could be really
explain why I've been dumped by so many
good women but I think I wasn't kidding
but I think Miami will always be this
magical place for me and it was the
scene of some of my most the most fun
I've ever had I landed there is Miami
bureau chief for the New York Times
during a time of great strife there was
the Elian Gonzalez story which had no
middle ground and was extremely
difficult for me and I'd never been a
good beat reporter to keep on top of it
and and I kept you know kept say Mike I
kept doing the best I could but and it
you know it made me a little uneasy and
fidgety and and then of course we were
blessed later with the hanging chads
story
so my time is Miami bureau chief was
bracketed by the Elyon story and the
hanging chads story I miss Miami a lot
in the middle
I do because it's just I mean it you
know there's no better place to be a
reporter it's just the best place there
is to be a reporter it's the best place
for stories great weirdness is you know
but at the same time just like New
Orleans and like here just great people
with great stories to tell and I do miss
it I really miss it I only drank coffee
two places on earth and that's Miami
them little tiny them that taste like I
got heroin in or my shopton you know and
and and and New Orleans and I miss that
coffee a lot down there because I don't
get started real good in the mornings
let's go anyone else and how are we
doing on time Jake are we okay or should
we wrap it up is it really nine o'clock
oh well yeah let's I'm sorry y'all I
didn't mean to I didn't mean to run off
let's let's take two more and then we'll
go if there are two more people who just
might say hell I want to go home let's
take one more anybody else got anything
they want to ask let's go here oh great
this is embarrassing I'm not going to
answer well only only maybe to my wife I
noticed how much you talk I wonder if as
a child maybe you could have been
vaccinated with a phonograph needle the
truth is that there you had to talk my
people don't carry on one conversation
they'll start a conversation and someone
else sees no reason why they can't just
jump in and if you see one person
talking about a dog then but they'll be
halfway through it and another one of my
aunt's oh yeah that's a good story but
how about this dog
so I know you're done
I oh so you know this this practice but
yeah it you know talking's free it's fun
well the truth is I do talk too much and
the truth is I appreciate you guys
listening and not fidgeting in your
seats
or getting up or looking at me mean like
I thank you for coming out here very
much
if you'll give us just a minute to get
outside Rick will sign all your books
thank you I really do appreciate it
and I really I didn't know we were going
so long I'm sorry I can't hold my
stomach in much longer